i grew up in new york city the streets
were paved with different colors of
broken glass our bikes would catch flats
a lot but it was the terrain of
champions
naked music and rhymes was extremely
therapeutic for what i was seeing in the
streets
well hip-hop was always truthful it
uncovered the ugliness in american
society from the man on the ground
i'm going to create a brand new song
just for masterclass
you'll see my writing process in real
time
[Music]
yeah
test one two
big nines old money new money i'll be
teaching you how to find your
inspiration find your flow
and how to turn your life experiences
into music i hear my calling heart
pounding on my
as a young man my raps were about me
still maintaining my sanity on a
beautiful level in this ugly world
you are the one that can change your
reality and
uplift the art of ramen by being brave
and bold enough to try to do something
that hasn't been done
go into a quiet room buckle your seat
belt and get ready for this ride we can
light up i'm nas
and this
is masterclass
[Music]
hey
[Music]